스포츠를 사랑하는 토스 이런 게 나와야 되는데
올림픽 하나 알아?
다 몰라요
다 몰라요 진짜 몰라요
진짜?
이제 JTBC가 IOC로부터 중재권을 사온 거는
2019년입니다
그렇게 오래된 얘기예요?
사실상
덕비인 거죠
이렇게 알뜰하게 치러진 평창도 이런 상황인데
동계올림픽이 지속 가능성이 있다고 좀 보시나요?
결국은
소비문화위면의 경제 이야기 비주류경제학 호스트를 맡은
저는 토스 김창선이고요
저는 재무덕후 이재용입니다
이번 주 비주류경제학 주제는
올림픽인데요
게스트로 박재민님 모셨습니다
어서오세요
반갑습니다
스포츠 덕후 박재민입니다
아
박훈님
재민님은 십잡수로 유명하시더라고요
어떤 일들을 좀 하고 계시길래
그런 별명을 가지신 거예요?
직업이라는 것을 정의를 어떻게 하느냐에 따라서
좀 달라질 것 같긴 한데
대학에서 강의를 했던 교수
국제심판
조만간 드라마로 복귀하는데
배우 생활이나
운동선수로도 오래 활동을 했었고
그러면서 여기까지 왔네요
원래는 하나의 일에 집중하는 것보다는
여러 일을 다 경험해보시는 걸 좋아하시는 편이세요?
그게 되게 적합한 표현인 것 같아요
경험해보는 걸 좋아했어요
경험주의자
경험을 해보는데
좀 어설픈 경험이라고 해야 될까?
야 너 선수들이
경기장 뒤에서 뭐 하는 줄 알아?
그게 너무 알고 싶었던 것 같아요
그럼 선수가 돼야 된다
선수가 돼야 된다
잘 못해도 선수가 돼야 되는 거야
그러려면 내가 선수가 돼야겠구나
그래서 선수가 된 거예요
이게 말처럼 쉬운 게 아니잖아요
그러니까
그거에 맞는 실력을 갖춰야 되잖아요
실력은 상관이 없죠
아 그래요?
상관이 없죠
왜냐하면 나의 목적은
잘 타는 선수가 아니라
경험해보는 선수였으니까
말은 재밌게 하시지만
그 뒤에서는 엄청난 집중과 노력이 분명히
뒷받침하고 있다는 게 좀 느껴져요
그렇게 하다가 해설위원까지 하게 되셨고
그러면 이번 밀라노 동계올림픽에서도
재민님의 스노우보드 해설을 저희가 들을 수 있나요?
못 듣습니다
없어요
저 찾지 마요
왜 못 들어요 이번에는?
일단 가장 큰 이유는 중계권이 없어요
이번에는 우리가 흔히 알고 있는 레거시 미디어
지상 3사 KBS SBS MBC가 중계권이 없습니다
JTBC가 단독 중계를 하는 걸로 결정이 됐기 때문에
지금 고민 중이에요
스트리밍으로 따로 찾아뵐까
그런 식으로 해설해볼까
어쨌든 해설위원을 오래 좀 하셨을 텐데
이렇게 한 방송사가 올림픽 독점 중계를 하는 경우가
좀 많으시네요
좀 흔한가요?
없죠
이번에 좀 특수한 케이스예요?
2010년에 SBS가 한번 월드컵과 동계올림픽을 시도했던 적이 있고
그때 굉장히 화제가 됐고 사회적으로 논의가 이뤄졌던 게
시청자의 보편적 볼 권리에 대해서
볼 권리
어떻게 방송국이 스탠스를 잡아야 되는가가
굉장히 사회적인 화두가 됐었어요
결국 이제 구조를 알아야 되는데
중계권은 IOC에서 사오는 겁니다
그러면 중계권을 사오는 게
한 방송국이 제작을 하면서 중계권을 재판매를 하죠
중간방송사가 있고 재판매를 해서
보통은 KBS, SBS, MBC가 돌아가면서
주간방송 재구매를 했었어요
JTBC라고 하는 복병이 숨어있었던 거죠
그러면서 여기에서 조금 마찰이 있었어요
불협화음이
결과적으로는 JTBC가 재판매를 하지 않기로 하면서
첫 번째는 국민이 시청자들이 가장 피해를 받고
두 번째는 선수들이
저도 방송하기 전에
여기저기 물어봤거든요
다음 주에 우리 올림픽이잖아요
올림픽 하는 거 알아?
다 몰라요
다 몰라요 진짜 몰라요
진짜?
올림픽해?
어디서 해? 이런 기초적인 질문도 하고
그러더라고요
그러면 일단 중계권을 떠나서
올림픽에 대해서 거시적인 얘기를 해보면 좋을 것 같은데
과거에 비해서 올림픽이라는 국제 경기
국제 대회에 대한 관심이
좀 떨어지고 있는 것 같다는 느낌이 좀 들어요
재민님도 동의를 하시는지?
IOC가 실제로 굉장히
인기가 떨어지는 것에 대한 우려를 이미 인지를 하고 있었습니다
그래서 여러 가지 방안을, 대안을 내놓고 있는데
그 중에 하나가 아젠다 2020이라고 하는 프로젝트를
2010년대에 냈었어요
뭐냐 하면 그전까지는 IOC 위원들이 종목을 다 선정해
그리고 뭐가 들어오고 뭐가 나갈지도
다 IOC에서 관장을 했습니다
그런데 어떤 개최국에는
거기서만 특별하게 인기가 있는 종목들이 있단 말이에요
그럴 수 있죠
그래서 2020년 도쿄올림픽을 기점으로
야 너네가 하고 싶은 종목 다섯 개 정하는
티켓을 줄게
그래서 야구를 했고
야구를 했고 서핑을 했고
파리 같은 경우는 브레이킹을 했고
그러니까 새로운 시청자를 끌어모을 수 있는
그런 종목들을 발굴하려고 하는 거군요
그리고 그 나라의 관객의 유입을
최대한 극대화 시키는 거죠
왜냐하면 이제 티켓 수익, 관중 수익을 극대화 시킬 수도 있고
광고 수입을 극대화 시킬 수 있기 때문에
결국은 기존에 있는 종목들의 팬층이 나이가 많아지고 있다는
아이오씨 판단이 깔려 있습니다
이미 아이오씨에서도 그걸 좀 감지하고 있고
그런 문제를 타개하기 위한 그런 노력을 하고 있군요
이번엔 재용님한테 궁금한데
올림픽은 어떻게 보면 전 세계에서 온 온갖 수많은 선수와 관객들
미디어, 여행객들이 모이는 대규모 행사잖아요
올림픽 한 번 할 때 비용이 어느 정도 되는지
이런 것도 저희가 알 수 있어요
살짝 이제 이런 건 정확하게는 알 수 없으나
기사로 이제 대략 얼마 정도 들었다라는 이야기는 많이 나오고요
당연히
많이 듭니다
대표적으로
하계올림픽부터 한번 생각을 해보면
이제 최근에 있었던 파리올림픽이 이제 85억 달러를 썼다고 해요
85억 달러?
10조 원 내외를 썼다고 하고
그 전에 있었던 도쿄올림픽은 350억 달러
아 350억이요?
그리고 그 앞단 리우는 130억 달러
또 2008년에 베이징은 527억 달러
똑같습니다 동계올림픽도 비슷해요
2022년 베이징이 한 160억 달러 좀 많이 썼고
평창이 이제 13.8조 원
그러니까 대략 100억 달러죠
평창은 좀 덜 썼고 2014 소치는 510억 달러
여기는 한 70조죠 지금 환율로 하면
편차가 엄청 크네요 대회마다
어떤 차이가 있냐면 인프라를 많이 지어야 된다
예를 들어서 뭐 소치 이런 데들은 뭔가 이렇게 도로도 깔고 건물도 짓고
해야 되는 데들은 굉장히 많이 들어가고
이 소치가 인구가 40만밖에 안 돼요
되게 작은 도시에서 하다 보니까
되게 작은 도시니까 다 깔아야 되겠네
도로도 처음부터 까고
그러니까
대회들은 굉장히 많이 들고
그렇게 치면 사실 평창은 되게 아껴서 아껴서 지은 거예요
합리적으로 했다
진짜 아껴졌고
그나마 이제 최근에 이제 파리가 이제 확 줄어들었거든요
파리올림픽에서
파리도 대도시이고 원래 인프라 빠방하고 하다 보니까
요즘에는 좀 이런 회의들이 많이 있어요
그러니까 너무 나라에서 인프라 짓는다고 막 수십조원 때려박고
이만큼 돈 쓰는 게 맞나
맞냐 해서 요즘에는 IOC도 최대한 아껴 써라
효율적으로 하자
아껴 쓰고 있는 인프라 최대한 활용하고
이런 분위기로 많이 바뀌고 있는 것 같아요
월드컵은 어때요?
월드컵도 올림픽만큼의
비슷합니다
월드컵도 비슷하고
2022년 카타르가 제일 최근 대회였잖아요
거기가 이제 2,200억 달러
우리나라 돈으로 300조
딴 데 뭐 10조 20조 쓸 때
카타르는 도시를 새로 지었죠
우리 경제학과 모르겠고
이러면 보여줄 거야
돈은 땅에서 또 나니까
땅에서 석유로 이제 하면
그 앞단에 러시아는 140억 달러
브라질도 한 14조
그러니까 대략 한 10조에서 20조원 사이를 쓰고
있고 이 정도 수준에서
세계대회가 동계라고 싸고
월드컵이라고 더 싸고
이런 거 전혀 없습니다
그냥 인프라
인프라를 얼마나 짓냐에 따라
세계대회가 굉장히 큰 편차가 난다
그래서 사실 우리나라 평창올림픽도
가장 많이 돈이 들어갔던 게 KTX란이에요
아 철도건설하는
철도건설 빼면 사실 비용이 엄청나게 줄어듭니다
되게 효율적인 대회에요
정말 효율적으로 했어요
이게 되게 재밌는 게
올림픽의 이제 예산 구조
를 좀 들여다보면 이게 이해가 돼요
야 세계 최고 선수 다 와서 경기해봐
그러면 그 재미를 방송으로 해가지고
중계권을 가져가
IOC가 벌어
근데 문제는 이 플랫폼을 누가 만들어?
국가가 만들어
국가가 만든 플랫폼이에요
IOC가 일종의 콘텐츠 같은 거
그렇죠
그걸로 돈을 버는
이게 정치화가 될 수밖에 없는 게
들어가는 예산은 전부 국가 예산으로
IOC가 일절 도와주지 않거든요
인프라 구축은
IOC에 대해서 점점 궁금해지네요
자 이렇게 돈이 많이 들어가는 행사인데
반대로 돈을 그러면 얼마나 벌어들이는지
그것도 좀 궁금해요
얼마나 벌어들인지를 예시를 들기 위해서
평창 조직위원회의 수익을 한 번씩 찾아봤는데요
이제 두 가지를 생각해야 돼요
각 국가의 조직위원회에서 벌어들인 돈이 얼마냐
그리고 IOC에서 벌어들인 돈이 얼마나
이원해서 생각을 할 필요가 있는데요
일단 조직위원회 측면에서 보면
평창 기준으로 봤을 때
벌어들인 돈이 한 13조 9천억 원 정도라고 얘기를 하는데
근데 사실은 13조 9천억 원이
다 벌어들인 게 아니라
그 중에 12조가 국비
조직위원회 측면에서 나의 수입은
일단 12조는 국가나 지역사회에서 주셨고요
지역의 기업 후원금이 1조 1천억 원 정도 들어왔고
그 다음에 IOC가 배당으로 준 게 4,400억
그리고 IOC가 TOP라고 해서
코카콜라 삼성전자 같은
탑티어 광고주들한테 돈을 받아서
그것도 후원 나눠주거든요
그것 한 2,400억
그러니까 IOC한테 배당받은 거는 6,800억인 거예요
그 외에 이제 짜라하게 모아봤더니
13조 9천억은 한 14조 정도 벌었습니다
사실상 국비인 거죠
그러니까 이거를 흑자로 마감했다고 하기엔
국비가 12조니까
사실상 12조의 세금을 쓴 거다
약간 이렇게 보여지고요
이제 IOC는 어떻게 벌어들이냐라고 보면
이 마감을 4년 단위로 합니다
왜냐하면 이제 4년 동안
동계와 하계가 이루어지기 때문에
4년을 한 사이클로 보고 있고
예전에 있었던 IOC의 한 사이클은
2021에서 2024년까지예요
우리는 4년 동안 7.7 빌리언 달러
우리나라 돈 한 10조 원 정도를 벌었습니다
그리고 그중에 55%는
방송 중개권으로 55%를 벌었고요
TOP 마케팅 프로그램이라고 해서
그런 탑티어 광고주들의 마케팅 프로그램으로
36% 그 외에 기타 여러 가지
자잘하게 해가지고 한 10% 벌었습니다
이런 식으로 공지를 하고 있어요
IOC가 쓰는 돈은 없나요 진짜로?
IOC가 쓰는 돈은 이제
IOC가 매년 연간 보고서를 쓰거든요
제일 하단에 이제
재무적으로 어떻게 했는지 결산된 거 나오는데
그 재무적인 결산 항목의 첫 페이지가 항상
90% 대 10%로 공지를 해요
그게 뭐냐면
우리는 무조건 벙거의 90%는 나눠준다
각 국가들과 플레이어들한테 나눠준다
되게 강조해요
오히려 그렇게 강조하니까 의심스럽네요
절대 그 표가 매년 사라지지 않아
우리는 절대 9대 1의 원칙을 어기지 않습니다
여러분 의심하지 마십시오
IOC는 이따가 좀 더 한번
깊게 판매해야 될 것 같아요
비주얼 경제학 올림픽 편
본격적인 이야기를 시작해 볼 텐데요
자 눈과 얼음 위에서 펼쳐지는 축제지만
어마어마한 돈이 오가는 비즈니스인 것 같아요
중개권 얘기를 좀 깊게 들어가면 좋을 것 같은데
올림픽 중개권은 어떤 방식으로
팔리는 건지가 좀 궁금해요
재민 님이 좀 답변해 주시죠
올림픽은 다시 말씀드리지만
기영리 조직이라고 하지만
돈을 벌어야 되고
돈을 벌기 위해서 정말 많은 수단을 쓰고 있고
가장 IOC에서 큰 비중을 차지하는 수익은 중개권입니다
그중에 IOC의 어떤 그런 경제적 가치에서
제일 중요한 게 중개권이다
그래서 OBS를 만들어냅니다
방송사 이름이에요 OBS가?
올림픽 브로케스팅 서비스
IOC가 자체 방송국을 둬요
꿈의 직장이에요
KBS에서도 스포츠고 PD님들이 OBS에 파견됐다고
파견 가는 형식으로
그렇죠 그래서 OBS에서 원천 스트리밍 재료를 제작을 하고
이거를 표준화시켜서 팔기 시작했죠
그럼 각 나라별로 중간 방송사가
그거를 입찰을 통해서 중개권을 산다
그럼 만약에 이 안에 나라별로 채널이 몇 개 더 있다
그럼 이 중간 방송사가 재판매를 한다
일반적인 룰이라면 그걸 이제 재판매를 해서
다 같이 보게 해야 되는데
우리만 할래 이렇게 된 상황이라고 볼 수 있죠
아마 GTBC도 처음부터 우리만 할래는 아니었을 거예요
제가 알기로는 처음부터 그러진 않았고
무조건 재판매를 하고 싶었는데
맞춰주기가 좀 어려웠던
재용 님은 좀 어떻게 보시는지 궁금해요
이번 중개권 독점 계약을 한 번
좀 정리를 해 주신다면
네 이 사건이 지금 2026년에 우리가 얘기를 하고 있지만
사실은 이제 JTBC가 IOC로부터 중개권을 사오기로 한 거는
2019년입니다
아우 그렇게 오래전 얘기에요?
우리가 17년 전에
왜냐면 이제 IOC도 그걸 이제 4년 단위로 계약을 하기 때문에
미리미리 팔아야 되니까
미리미리 이제 좀 이렇게
그래서 2019년에 이미 정했어요
그래서 2026년부터 32년까지는 동계하게 해가지고
두 번 두 번씩 해가지고
이제 JTBC랑 하기로 한다라고 결정을 했고
2014년에는 이제 피파랑 또 계약을 합니다
JTBC가요?
네 왜 그랬는지 모르겠는데
어 좀 욕심을 많이
좀 질렀어요 이제 2019년에 질렀는데
정확한 금액은 당연히 알 수는 없지만
업계 추정치로는 그렇게 해서 한 5억불 정도 썼을 것이다
5억불?
5억불 그니까 5억불이면 7천억
7천억?
어 7천억 정도는 썼을 것이다
어우 방송사로서는 상당한 돈일 것 같고
엄청난 숫자죠 왜냐면은 지금
JTBC가 1년 매출액이 3,800억이에요
연간 매출액의 두 배를 쓴 거란 말이죠
물론 이제 대회가 여러 개로 나눠져 있긴 하지만
네
다른 뭐 중개권이랑 비교해볼 만한 게 있어요?
프로야구
프로야구를 티빙이
프로야구를 3년 동안 1,350억에 샀습니다
음
일단 7천억이 훨씬 많죠
그쵸 그쵸
쿠팡플레이가 EPL 축구를 6년 동안 4,200억
어
1년에 700억 주고 샀어요
근데 여긴 7천억 주고 샀단 말이죠
근데 프로야구는 1년에 130경기가 3년 동안 돌아가는 건데
3년에 1,350억
그니까요
근데 여기는 지금 올림픽 4번에 월드컵 2번 해가지고 7천억
그니까 월드컵 올림픽 아무리 묶어도
이게 지속적으로 경기가 있는 게 아니라
그 시즌에 한 달 내외 정도만 할 수 있는 건데
7천억을 주고 사오는
기간 대비 경기수 대비 압도적으로 비싼 거죠
비싸게 사오는 거죠
네 압도적으로 비싸긴 하죠
어 근데
연간 매출액 두 배 가까운 데다가
그러니까 영업이익도 아니고 매출액의 두 배
이미 영업이익은 JTBC가 굉장히 오랫동안 적자를 오랫동안 누적을 해왔어요
아 심지어 흑자도 아닌 상대
오랫동안 적자였어요
어 근데
오래됐죠
어 오랫동안 적자였는데
이제 생각해보면 JTBC가 2019년부터 질르기 시작했단 말이죠
참고로 JTBC가 15년 정도 된 기업인데
흑자였던 적이 한 두 번 있어요
그렇게 많지도 않네요
흑자였던 적이 2017년이나 2018년 딱 두 번 있었어요
연도로 잘라보면
자신감이 있는 거지
일단 2017년, 2018년 자신감
우리 그래도 한
아 상승 그래프를 시작했다
어 상승 그래프를 이제 시작했다
2019년에 이제 한번 이 질서
아 저 고인물들
삼사라는 저 고인물들을 깨치고
이제 내가 이제 넘버원으로 갈 수 있는 찬스가 왔다
그래서 아마 질렀던 거 같기도 하고요
그리고 아마 독점의 힘을 믿지 않았을까 라는 생각이 들어요
독점하면 온다
내가 이걸 사면은
내가 이걸 사서 예를 들면은 이제 여섯 개 대회에 7천억 쓴 거니까
대회당 한 천억 조금 넘게 쓰는 건데
이거 대파리 해가지고
되겠지
내가
크게 질렀어도 나중에 보전 되겠지
광고 수익까지 있습니다
말이 되는데
그리고 그때의 스포츠인가요?
인기가 지금보다 훨씬 좋았거든요
음 19년에
OTT도 사실 지금 우리가 흔히 얘기하는 뭐 넷플릭스나 디즈니 플러스처럼
이런 OTT도 활성화되기 전이었고
지금보다 레거시 미디어 TV라고 하는 매체가 갖고 있는 힘이 훨씬 강했어요
음
그쵸
사람들이 다 그것만 보니까
이 몇 년 사이에 2019년에 지르고 나서 보니
어 코로나도 왔네
OTT라는 환경이 고려가 되지 않았던 당시의 어떤 결정이기도 하죠
만약에 여섯 개 대회를 JTBC가 혼자 다 한다
그럼 진짜
쉽지 않을 것 같고요
제가 볼 때는 그래도 여섯 개 대회가 있으니까
하나 할 때마다 상황을 좀 볼 것 같아요
예를 들어서 이번 동계올림픽이 잘 된다
다시 연락해서
월드컵 안 하실 거예요?
다시 한 번 얘기하고
월드컵 흔히 했다
우리가 16강 갔다
그럼 다음 대회에 이제 다시
약간 이런 식으로 아직 남은 찬스들이 있기 때문에
그런 좀 그 후대의 각을 좀 보고 있지 않을까라는 생각을 합니다
지금까지 중계권을 중심으로 방송 산업 이야기를 해 봤는데
이번에는 저희가
아이오씨라는 조직에 대해서 한번 깊게 파보면 좋을 것 같아요
일단 재호님한테 먼저 궁금한데
아이오씨도 재무제표에서 특이할 만한 점이 있나요?
중계권 수익이 1번이죠
중계권 수익이 절반 이상
50에서 60% 정도 항상 차지하고 있고
이제 광고 수익 그게 이제 한 30%에서 40%
물론 그 외에 이제 기타 운영과 관련된
이제 자잘한 시설 수입이나 운영 수익 같은 것들도 한 10% 정도 받고 있고
특징은 현금이 되게 많아요
아 현금이 많아요?
돈을 많이 벌고 싶어서 그런 건지 모르겠는데
보수적으로 올림픽 망할 수도 있잖아요
근데 내가 이걸 가진 돈을 조직위원회들한테 다 나눠주면
그러면 이제 다음 올림픽 못하는 거잖아요
그러니까 자금을 보수적으로 운영할 수밖에 없어요
보수적으로 운영하고 있는
그래서 보면 현금이 되게 많아요
한 이제 38억불 우리나라 돈으로 한 5조 원 수준의 현금을 들고 있어요
5조 원의 현금이 있어요?
그 정도면 들고 있지 못하는 것 같아요
너무 많은데?
어디에 있는 거야?
그러니까 연간 매출액이
2024년이 파리올림픽이 있었던 해인데
그 해의 매출액이 44억불이거든요?
근데 그거 다 쓰고도 현금이 38억불이 남아있어요
그러니까 대충 1년 올림픽 하나 치를 정도의 현금은 쥐고 있다
그러니까 이 국제 범죄 조직들이 어디 막 미국 연방은행
그럴 게 아니에요
슬슬 오자를 가야 돼요
그 대신에 사람은 별로 없어요
왜냐면 이제 이벤트
약간 초대형 이벤트 회사 같은 거잖아요
그냥 그때그때 헤쳐 모여가지고
평소에 할 거 그렇게 많이 없고
대회할 때만 이제 하면 되니까
그냥 거대하고 보수적이고
현금 지게 많이 들고
있는 이벤트 회사
정도의 느낌을 딱 받았어요
정확하십니다
플랫폼이
근데 그만큼 올림픽 대회라는
그 행사가 부흥하고 흥하는 게 되게 중요하잖아요
근데 이렇게 보수적으로 움직이는 거면
좀 되게 굼뜨게 움직이는 거 아닌가요?
더 기민하게 움직여야 되는 거 아닌지?
굼뜨죠
실제로 현장에서 실무를 하다 보면
IOC의 행정 구조가 굉장히 보수적이고
굉장히 권위적이에요
하라면 해!
그래서 실제로 어느 정도냐 하면
IOC 위원이 되면
각 나라의 이제 대사급으로 인정을 받고
IOC 위원장이 그 나라를 방문한다
그러면 거의 국가 수반처럼 국빈 대접을 받는 게
어떤 나라의 대통령이 온 것처럼
아니 생각해 보세요
사단법인 그냥 이사장이에요
근데 대통령을 만날 수 있다는 게
오히려 너무 큰 권위가 부여되다 보니
그러니까 그 권위에 맞게 일부러 느리게 움직이는 거 같다는 생각도 좀 들어요
굳이 급하지 않은 거지
내가 대빵인데
약간 독점의 폐해이기도 하고
너무 고인물이어가지고
그러니까 현금을 5조 원이나 왜 들고 있는지를
조금 더 이해가 되는 거 같아요
왜냐면 사실 그렇게 뭐 돈이 많이 필요한 조직이 아니고
운영비가 많이 들어간 조직 때문에 사람도 없고
굳이 뭐 5조 원 현금 들고 있을 필요 없어요
기민하게 움직이면
근데 기민하게 움직이면 실제 안 움직여도 되잖아
어 내가 가만히 있어도 다 오는데
안 움직여도 되잖아 내가 현금 5조 원 있고 인사하러 오는데
1년에 2.2천억 이상 들어오는데
그러니까 기민하게 움직이지 않아도 되는
굉장히 보수적이고 권위적이게 될 수밖에 없는
독점인 거 같아요
저희가 올림픽을 중심으로 숫자 얘기를 좀 하고 있는데
정작 올림픽의 경제적 효과에 대한 논란은 끊이지 않는 거 같아요
하얀 코끼리 논란이라고 부르기도 하는데
이게 좀 어떤 의미인가요 재능님
올림픽 기반 시설 인프라 스트럭처를 만들고 나서
올림픽 이후에는 쓰지 않는
경기장은 있는데
방대한데
쓸 못하는
용도가 없어
이런 사례들이 굉장히 많았죠
이게 IOC 입장에서는 비판을 피해갈 수가 없는 게
올림픽 경기장 스포츠 시설들은 용도가 굉장히 제한적이에요
딱 하나를 위해서 만들어지거든요 어떤 경기 하나
스키 점프하는 게 그렇게 논다고 하더라고요
우리가 가서 점프할 수가 없잖아
가끔 예능 찍으러 좀 가는 거 같긴 한데
가장 대표적인 이미지가 소치 올림픽 끝나고
정말 흉물스럽게 변해서 거의 무슨 공포의 집같이
찍은 그런 연작들이 있는데
그거 보면 진짜 올림픽이 끝나고
이렇게 거품이 열기가 끝나고 나면 이렇게 변하는구나
이렇게 체감하게 되는 거 같아요
실제로 브라질 리우 올림픽 때 쓰였던
이 수영장 같은 경우는 올림픽 끝나자마자
6주 안에 곰팡이와
뭔가 부유물들
아무도 관리 안 한 거네
그런 것을 본다면
결국은 IOC도 이제 고민이 생기는 게
넌 이거 어떻게 할 거야
어떻게 좀 재활용할 수 있어
그래서 베이징이 올림픽을 두 번 할 수 있었던 게
야 우리 하계 때 썼던 그 경기장 그대로 동계 때도 쓸게
새로 안 짓고
좀 개조만 해서
지금 IOC의 기조는 그래요
저희가 아까 봤던 굉장히 합리적인 비용으로
경기를 했던 평창올림픽
평창올림픽은 끝나고 좀 어땠어요
그 당시에 만들어진 시설이나 아니면 경기장 같은 경우는
직후에는 굉장히 안 좋았죠
직후에는 이거예요
강릉에 아이스하키 경기장을 세웠어요
근데 문제는 고향에도 있단 말이에요
그러면 인구가 많은 수도권에서 굳이 강릉을 갈 것이냐
안 가지
그래서 사실 그 당시에도 평창군에 계속 얘기를 했던 게
서울하고 분산 개최를 해서 아이스하키만 여기다 하자
평창군이 지어서 강행을 한 건데
결국 그 경기장에 놀게 된 거예요
왜냐하면 계획은 있지만
실제로 가겠다는 사람이 안 간다고 하면
그렇죠 강제할 수 없는 거니까
그런 식으로 경기장에 놀기 시작한 거예요
되게 재미있는 에피소드가
스피드스케이트가 펼쳐졌던 오바리티가
오발 경기장을 강릉에서 업을 하니까
대형 냉장고로 쓰자
근데 저는 그 생각이 너무 획기적이라고 생각했어요
나쁘지 않은데 안 될 건 뭐야
어떻게든 쓰면 되는 거 아니야?
쓰면 되는 거니까
그런데 엄청난 반발을 하면서
몇백억짜리 경기장을 나랏돈으로 쥐어놓고 그걸 냉장고로 쓰고 있냐
근데 그 오발 경기장에서
한산이라고 하는 이순신 영화를 찍었어요
엄청나게 큰
푸르마키
그린 스크린
블루 스크린을 뒤에다가
천장에다 걸어가지고 내려놓고
거기 이제 파녹선더 때
거북선더 때
회전을 찍었군요
회전을 거기서 찍었어요
그래서 스튜디오로 활용될 수 있는 세계 최초의 사례가
대한민국 강릉 오발 경기장에서 이루어졌고
최근에 SNS에 아마 여러분들 보셨을 수도 있는데
슬라이딩 센터라고 해서
봅슬레이 경기장이 있어요
테마파크처럼 즐기더라고요 봅슬레이를
스폰지 봅슬레이를 만들어서
지금 그거를 하고 있어요
완전 붐업 돼가지고 지금 예약이 안 돼요
재밌나보다
시간이 걸리더라도 어쨌든
그 당시에 만들어졌던 시설들을 활용하는 방안
여러 가지 방안들을 다 시도를 해보고 있네요
재용님한테 좀 궁금한데
개최극들은 항상
올림픽으로 인해서 수조원의 경제 효과가 발휘된다
20조, 100조 이렇게 얘기하잖아요
그런 건 도대체 어떻게 추산하는 건지가 좀 궁금하더라고요
좀 찾아봤습니다
현대경제연구원에서
평창 올림픽의 경제 효과는
64조 9천억 원이라고 발표를 했어요
64조 9천억 원이다
그래서 인터넷에 찾으면
상세 계산내역도 찾을 수 있거든요
궁금해가지고 64조?
64조는 왜 그랬을까라고 찾아보면
일단 기본적으로
직접효과가 21조, 간접효과가 43조인데
직접효과는 쉽게 말해서
들어와서 티켓 사고 먹고 관광객하고 이런 것들이
예를 들어서 외국인들이 7,200억 쓴다 그러면
7,200억을 쓰고 끝이 아니라
생산유발계수라는 게 있어요
왜냐면 외국인들이
예를 들어서 와서 치킨을 사 먹으면
치킨 사장님이 또 가서 고기를 사 먹고
고기 사장님이 또 생선을
약간 이런 식으로
경제라는 게 순환하잖아요
그래서 이제 아마 한국은행이었나
생산유발계수를 공시하는 데가 있는데
그래서 이제 예를 7,200억 썼으면
생산유발액은 1조 2천억이야
그래서 실제로 직접적으로
내국인이 쓴 거, 외국인이 쓴 거
올림픽 대회 경비로 쓴 거 다 합치면
2조 8천억인데
생산유발액은 4조 7천억이야
이런 식으로 뭔가 개수를 꼭 하고요
그리고 간접효과가 좀 재밌는 게
간접효과는 그런 식으로 해요
우리가 올림픽을 하고 나면
사람들이 관광을 많이 올 것이야
바로 집에 안 가고 서울도 관광하고
바로 집에 안 가는 게 아니라
이미지가 좋아져서
그 이후에도
이미지가 좋아서
그 당시에 우리나라의 외국인 관광객이
1년에 한 천만 명 정도였는데
한 10%는 늘지 않을까?
아, 새로 오는 관광객들
1년에 추가적으로 100만 명 정도는 더 오지 않을까?
그러면 그 사람들이 한 번 오면
1년에 1,600달러는 쓰지 않을까?
그건 나름 통계가 있을 거예요
1,600달러 쓰고 환율 곱하면
18조 정도 나오는데
18조에 생산유발 개수를
또 그걸 붙어요
그러면 한 32조 정도가 나오거든요
앞으로 향후 10년 동안
사람들이 100만 명씩 더 오는데
그 사람들이 1,600달러 정도 써주면
18조 정도의 효과가 있는데
생산유발 개수를 곱하면
32조 정도 되지 않을까?
이런 식으로 계산을 하고
다 아닐까 아닐까 아닐까
약간 시리즈 같은데요
그렇죠
마지막으로 기업의 브랜드 인지도가 올라가지 않을까?
우리나라 상위 100개 기업들이
인지도를 1% 올리려면 얼마를 써야 될까?
그러면 한 11조 정도 효과가 있었겠다
그런 식으로
말은 돼요, 말은 되는데
저는 그러니까 예를 64조라고 한다면
64조 오케이, 인정
저는 인정이라고 치면
64조의 경제 효과가 다
어떤 국가에게 귀속되느냐
도움이 되느냐
GDP가 늘어나느냐라고 봤을 때
그 64조 사실은 좀 약간 중복이에요
사실 그 안에서 부가가치가 창출된 거는
그러니까 내가 예를 들어서 재료를 만 원에 사서
만 오천 원에 물건을 팔면은
내 매출액은 만 오천 원이지만
부가가치는 오천 원이잖아요
근데 부가가치만 치면은
이거에 한 40% 정도 되지 않을까?
그리고 만약에 국가 입장에서
세율을 얹어서 우리가 세수를 얻게 될 텐데
그럼 64조를 만약에
경제 효과가 있으면
부가가치가 한 40% 있고
그 안에 보통 우리나라 전반적으로 한
실효세율이 한 20% 내외 되거든요
20% 세수 땡기고 나면
대략 경제활동의 효과에 한 8% 남는다
4조에서 5조 원 정도가
드라마틱하게 해도 세수로 돌아오는 한 5조 원 정도
이다라는 게 이제 제 생각이기 때문에
평창이 물론 되게 잘 치른 대회이긴 하지만
투입된 거에 비해서 이득이냐 보면은
이득이라고 말하기는 좀 어렵다
제 생각이죠
이렇게 알뜰하게 치러진 평창도 이런 상황인데
앞으로 동계올림픽 지속 가능성이 있다고 보시나요?
그래서 요즘에 올림픽을 지원하는 국가들이 줄고 있다는 얘기는
경쟁이 예전만 못한 거 같아요
옛날에 10개국 9개국 경쟁을 많이 했는데
특히 이제 하계올림픽 같은 경우는
재작년에 파리가 했잖아요
그리고 이제 내후년에 LA 하는데
파리랑 LA가 마지막으로 두 개 국가가 진청을 해가지고
아 겨우 채워서
이게 경쟁이 아니라 두 개 들어왔네
그러면 하나는 이번에 하고 하나는 다음에 하자
이렇게 된 거거든요
그래도 이제 지금 2030년쯤 되면은
그래도 좀 올라오는 약간 중동 국가들이나
동남아시아 국가나 신흥 국가들이 있거든요
결국은 이제 올림픽위원회에서 제일 권장하는 게
너희들 이제 경제성장 많이 했고
세계에 뭔가 보여주고 싶잖아
그러니까 이제 이거를 쇼케이스로
당신들은 달라졌다는 걸 보여줘 라는 형태로
당분간 좀 있지 않을까? 라는 생각을 또 하거든요
그래서 좀 들고 정 아니면은 이제
IOC가 전화하면 되거든요 평창에 다시
그거 아직 남았죠?
다시 쓰시면 됩니다
약간 이런 식으로 할 거라서
동계가 없어지진 않을 것 같아요
그럼 재민님은 어떻게 보세요?
동계올림픽이 지속 가능성이 있다고 좀 보시나요?
동계스포츠 같은 경우는 시즌이 워낙 짧다 보니까
비시즌 때 돈을 벌 수 있는 방법이 없어요
그러다 보니 선수들의 이윤 창출의 기회가
굉장히 제한적이다
그렇다면 이제 기업들의 후원이
거의 지금 e스포츠를 받들고 있는 유일한 기둥이자
마지막 기둥 같은 느낌이 있죠
설상은 롯데가 회장사로서
계속해서 신동빈 회장님이
개인 자금과 쏟아붓고 있고요
지원을 하고 있고
네 굉장히 오래됐고
빙상혁명 같은 경우는 최근에 이제 회장으로 선출된
삼보모터스라고 하는 자동차 부품회사
이제 회장이 들어왔고
이 기업들이 없으면 아예 돌아가지 않아요
아마 이 기조는 계속해서 이어질 수 밖에 없지 않을까
재웅님 외에도 좀 궁금해요
스포츠 중에서도 동계스포츠는 참 엘리트 영역도 그렇고
생활체육도 그렇고 접근하기가 어려운
되게 자생하기 어려운 그런 시장이잖아요
맞아요
어떤 그런 미래가 있을까요?
진짜 쉽지는 않겠다라는 생각이 들어요
왜냐하면 우리가 그런 접연을 넓히려면
우리 집 근처에 스케이트장이 있어야 돼요
많이 없어요
눈은 그렇게 눈은 댔고 빙상경기장이라도 있어야
저는 사실 남양주 살잖아요
저희 동네에 원래는 한 30년 전에는 이 스키장이 있었어요
거기 아파트가 됐거든요
저는 집 앞에 스키장이 있던 사람이었어요
근데 없어졌어요
자꾸 없어지고 하니까
쉽지는 않겠다 싶긴 하지만
그래도 우리가 조금 더 행복하게 살려면
스포츠를 좀 더 즐겨야 되지 않을까라는 생각을 해요
왜냐하면 이게 뭔가 이렇게 문화적인 다양성과
어떤 충족감을 느끼려면 우리가 해봐야지
우리가 삶이 좀 더 풍성해지는 거니까
그래서 우리가 좀 세금이 됐든 대기업이 지원금이 됐든
설매장 지어달라 이렇게 요구를 해서
그것들을 좀 즐기려는 어떤 것이 낭비가 아니다
생활체육에 투자하는 게
그렇죠 물론 그 스케이트장 짓는 게
경제성장이 도움이 되냐라고 하면 할 말은 없지만
그래도 그게 우리의 행복에 조금이라도 도움이 된다라고 한다면
그런 데다 돈을 쓸 여유는 조금 우리가 가져도 되지 않나라는 생각이 좀 듭니다
이렇게 동계 스포츠를 둘러싼 조금 무거운 이야기를 해봤는데
여전히 사람들은 올림픽 경기를 보면서
좀 울고 웃고 감동하는 포인트는 여전한 것 같아요
동계올림픽도 예외는 아닐 텐데
이번에 주목해볼 만한 경기 좀 어떤 게 있을까요?
아마도 스타가 나올 것 같습니다
스타 예상되나요?
스토로보드의 최가훈 선수입니다
여고생인데 올림픽 직전에 월드컵과 세계대회의 성적이
올림픽하고 거의 직결되거든요
이제 여러 가지 이유가 있는데
올림픽 투어라고 하는데 올림픽이 펼쳐질 때
이 심판들이 이 시즌의 시작부터 끝까지 똑같은 심판들이 심사를 해요
왜냐하면 약간 이런 거죠
대회 때는 계속 다른 선수가 우승했어요
그런데 올림픽 때 전혀 다른 선수가 우승해요
심판을 바뀌어서
그러면 이게 뭐야 이렇게 뜬금없이 논란을 줄이기 위해서
똑같은 심판원을 계속 배치해요 스토로보드는
그런데 이 똑같은 심판들이 계속 최가훈 선수에게 금메달을 주고 있거든요
흐름을 봤을 때 지금 기세가 왔다
우리나라에서도 나올 가능성이 굉장히 높아졌다
아니 그 얘기 나온 김에
스노우보드 경기 재밌게 보는 법 좀 알려주세요
관전 포인트 뭐 이런 게 있나요?
일단 박재민의 해설을 듣는 건데
스트레이딩 해주세요 스트레이딩
안 하니까
제가 봤을 때 가장 재밌게 보는 방법은
저 선수들이 기술을 보는 건 좀 어려워요 사실
우리가 일반인 눈으로 보기에는
보기 어렵기 때문에 빨리 AI로 저 선수의 이름을 걸어주세요
그냥 비하인드 스토리를 읽으면서 경기를 봐라
어떤 스토리가 있고 어떤 성장 과정을 거친 스토리인지 좀 알고
선수에 몰입해서 봐라 약간 이런 거
올림픽 네 번째 출전
알고 보니 이번 올림픽 최고령자
또 뭐 최연소자
이런 것들을 검색하면서 보는 게 가장 재밌는 거 같아요
캐릭터에 집중을 알아
소비문화 이면에 경제 이야기 비주류 경제와
오늘은 박재민 님과 올림픽 이야기를 나눠봤고요
저희는 다음 시간에 다른 주제로 돌아오겠습니다
감사합니다